what is the conversation like with a
wife who has been there and done that in
her own right
in the world of soccer what what what
are your conversations like you've got a
Lombardi Trophy and your wife is one of
the most decorated on the planet in her
profession
exactly yeah you know we're just
extremely proud and happy for one
another you know obviously as athletes
we have both from the moment I started
playing football and she started playing
soccer she had a goal of winning a World
Cup and I had a goal of winning a Super
Bowl and so when we're watching the
other person do what they love and doing
it at a high level and enjoy that
success that's the more extremely happy
for them only because we know that
they're extremely happy in that moment
our relationship wasn't built on
athletic success we started dating in
college before I even knew she played
soccer or she knew that I played
football this season right now that
we're in with the sports is extremely
difficult at times but it's a ton of fun
too so we do a lot of long-distance at
times but at the end of the day like I
said assembly a short season of her life
I'm extremely happy for all the success
you've had and she feels the same way
about me
do you have any advice marital advice
for Carson Wentz who just took the
plunge
oh no that guy's gonna be his his
marriage is gonna be rock solid he's a
he went about it exactly how you're
supposed to do it he's a man of of his
faith and so is his wife and her future
wife I should say it's Beyonce and
they're amazing people and they're gonna
be a very great married couple the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience